Hi guys Victoria lit here
Modern day TRAD wife
it's recently come to my attention
that not everybody knows the difference between a sundress
and a milk maid dress
I pulled out some of my dresses
to show you, explain what a sundress is vs milkmaid
I love wearing dresses so I have a couple here
here is a sundress
it does show a little bit more here
so it's not as modest
this is a sundress
yellow, flowy, strappy
great sundress
here is another sundress
flowy at the bottom, straps
this is a sundress
another option
the flowy at the bottom has an open back, sundress
I would say this is a sundress
But more of like a milk made inspired dress though
this is also another milk made dress
see it kind of like cinches at the waist
loose and flowy
kind of more of a modest top
love that
and this is another milk maid dress
longer version
more modest love that it has a little slit on the side here
but this is a milk maid dress
those are the differences